relationship to one's mother is one of
the most important relationships that
one will ever have in one's life the
care of a mother the nurturing of a
mother and these men decided to create a
child with the express intent of ripping
that child away from his mother it is
the most evil thing going on in the
country today other than
abortion other than killing babies in
the womb creating a baby for the purpose
of pulling that baby away from his
natural mother it's so profoundly evil
and more broadly treating people like
Commodities to be purchased on the open
market that is very very evil and it's
not just the Communists that we have to
blame for this and it's not just the
radical left that we have to blame for
this this is a product of capitalism
this is just a market and instead of a
regular Market that we're used to where
you can buy tumblers and you can buy
paper and you can buy all sorts of
actual Commodities now we are
commoditizing humans